is it just me or does Michael Shannon
look exactly like Quentin Tarantino's
long-lost brother tomorrow you cursed it
sounds like thunder what's not like
gonna take shelter is directed by jeff
nichols and stars Michael Shannon and
Jessica Chastain redhead alert it's
about a man who he works every day he
has a family him and his wife have a
little girl and he starts to have these
dreams about this thunderstorm and he
just can't seem to shake it out of his
head every night he dreams about
thunderstorms and about this giant
tornado that just wipes out everything
he just he gets these really strange
thoughts that something is coming some
kind of storm is going to come and so he
feels like he really needs to build this
shelter in his backyard so he starts to
add this addition to this underground
shelter it's wasting money and no one
understands what he's doing and you know
people just think he's nuts but he is
absolutely positive that something is
coming and he ain't gonna let anyone
tell him anything different I'm gonna
need green I don't like the kind of
mr. church this morning Curtis thinking
about cleaning up that storm shelter out
back this is a movie that's getting a
lot of praise largely from Michael
Shannon's performance and it's very well
deserved because he is extremely good in
this movie he never goes over the top he
never crosses that line of asking for
sentimentality his performance is very
real I'm ever halfway through the film I
was like you know what that's an actor
right there and I had to remind myself
that that is an actor he's not just some
guy that I was watching you know that's
a really good compliment because a lot
of times when actors give a performance
it's like it seems like they feel like I
have to be noticed right now I did do
something big here but no he's so
low-key here he is very good in this
film very good performance Jessica
Chastain also very good as well I'm
gonna build out the tornado shelter in
my backyard I could use some help
oh you want to do that for just means to
be done
you didn't say one word about this and
what are you worrying about it
when the film started I was thinking man
this is lit extremely well the film
looks very nice especially the dream
sequences that was actually my favorite
part of the film whenever he would have
one of these crazy dreams I was always
interested in seeing what was going to
happen what interesting visual trick
they were gonna use cuz there's actually
some really good special effects in
these scenes and I was very impressed
with the film is filmed in Ohio which is
kind of cool because they live in Ohio
with this and Ides of March and the
Avengers Ohio is becoming a hot
commodity this is a good movie because
it feels you really feel a growing sense
of dread man I'm doing this a lot of
films when you watch them sometimes you
know what the protagonist is going
through and you know the people who are
saying he's wrong you know they're wrong
so you're like okay I want I want him to
receive Redemption you know but in this
film you're not positive he might be
crazy it's you you know he could be nuts
or it could be something that is
realistically a problem and that's one
of the strengths of this movie because
you're never quite sure where you should
be with some of my issues with the film
art it is extremely slow paced and I
tend to like slow paced films so for me
to say that that it's a very slow-paced
film it's two hours long and I think
that there are some scenes that could
have been cut that were not necessary
for the continuation of the story that I
was interested in
[Music]
your mother was diagnosed with paranoid
student in her 30s I wanted to see more
of the dreams I really liked the dreams
he had they were very very well directed
and interesting and visually inventive I
really liked that story the progressive
story that was going forth with him and
his family I feel like there was some
added things on to the story like with
how the town felt about him that I
thought maybe could have been cut from
the film just to preserve the flow of
the central story I think that because
of the fact that I was bored in a
section of the middle of this movie it
kept it from being a movie that I loved
[Music]
anyone to be in it I did really like it
though and I'm going to for sure say
that this is a good and well-made film
and very well acted I'm going to give
take shelter a B+
[Music]
okay yeah I'm fine without spoiling
anything I will say that the film for me
was as a whole very satisfying and
that's that's all that's how I'll put it
I don't want to get into spoilers you
know me I hate that comments Tuckman's
square you stuck maniacs let me know
what you thought of Sir Hugh and if
you've seen take shell to tell me what
you thought of that too thanks very much
for watching if you liked this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]